hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
this is our annual holiday message for
2022. it's a rainy day here in Baltimore
my first December here in Baltimore so
if you hear little pitter patter of
raindrops on
um the window right next to me that's
why something we didn't get too much of
in La you know the idea behind the
holiday message that I started doing in
the first year the podcast would be a
solo episode but something shorter you
know not structured not deep not careful
more like a little reflective
self-indulgent perhaps more personal uh
set of opinions about I don't know
something that was inspired by the year
that had just passed whether it was with
the podcast or the outside world or
whatever is going on in my life
um and I've not been great about picking
topics I mean I think the actual holiday
message has been pretty good but I
really need to sit down and think uh
every single year about what to talk
about so this year I did think of a
couple things you know obviously my life
has been completely uprooted moving from
LA and Caltech to Baltimore and Johns
Hopkins uh still haven't yet moved into
the house that we will eventually move
into but that's coming later this week
so apologies if this is a quick and
dirty kind of episode but there were two
things that I kept thinking about that
certainly did not rise to the level of a
whole episode and and I realized there
was a through line through them that I
could combine together
and the two things were on the one hand
things going on online and in the tech
world and uh subset of that uh number
one Twitter obviously being bought by
Elon Musk changing in various ways I'm
very active on Twitter uh so that is
affecting me and the other one was the
FTX crypto collapse featuring Sam
bankman freed about which I'm certainly
no expert but nevertheless have some
opinions about
um so that's something that I wanted to
say something about in a very narrow
specific way I have no way of commenting
on the bigger picture there
the other uh idea was again coming to
Johns Hopkins and being now a professor
both in the physics departments and the
philosophy Department concentrating on
foundations of physics the idea that in
some sense what separates foundations of
physics from just regular physics
research is a certain kind of patience a
certain kind of value in thinking slowly
and carefully about things you know
physicists in some sense are always
thinking carefully about something but
they take some things they don't need to
think carefully about and put them in a
little box and don't worry about it and
in foundations of physics we really want
to open precisely those boxes and dig
into them and the Common Thread here is
of course precisely that value of
thinking slowly I think that in the
small number of things I have to say
about Twitter and FTX
um they mostly center around you know
boy people are really over valorizing
not thinking very carefully before doing
something and then watching as the
consequences blow up in their faces so
in some sense both of these things this
sort of online set of kerfuffles and the
difference between ordinary everyday
physics research and foundations of
physics comes down to an appreciation
for thinking slowly and carefully so the
uh title of course blatantly stolen from
Daniel kahneman's famous book Thinking
Fast and Slow he's a talking
psychologically about system one
thinking which is sort of all of our
beneath the surface subconscious
heuristic ways of thinking about the
world thinking fast ways that we already
have patterns for you know when you're
driving to work if you commute in the
same way every day you're more or less
on autopilot right you know there the
difference between playing guitar or
playing a sport as an expert who it's
all sort of automatic and you're in the
flow Zone versus someone who's
overthinking things like that and then
system two is the cognitive part of your
brain doing math problems writing text
or something like that where you really
have to sit and think carefully about it
but I want to sort of I'm just joking
about the title by going further than
that to thinking really slowly uh not
just being cognitive and doing a math
problem but
taking a breath thinking about the
context that some certain problem or
situation resides in and think about all
of the connotations and insinuations and
implications of what is going on now in
part this is kind of a cheap point to
make I'm not claiming that it is anyway
profound I suspect that most mindscape
listeners by virtue of a very strong
selection effect on whether or not you
listen to mindscape are already
convinced that thinking carefully and
and slowly about things is a good thing
but maybe by looking at some particular
examples we can flesh that out a bit and
I do want to stand up for the fact that
the people who don't always sit back and
think very carefully about things aren't
necessarily making mistakes there are
usually reasons for doing it that way
and so it's important to sort of
separate out the conditions under which
moving fast and breaking things which is
the Silicon Valley motto is the right
thing to do first is stepping back and
kind of trying to be more careful in the
china shop so that's what we're going to
be doing here today and I think that's
it holiday message 2022 happy holidays
to everyone out there and let's go
[Music]
I think perhaps of all the podcast
episodes I've done here at mindscape so
well over 200 now the one that I keep
quoting the most or coming back to the
most is the one with t Nguyen on the
philosophy of games and gamification
that one really stuck with me really
sort of shaped how I think about things
uh so you keep hearing me refer back to
it and part of that was because you know
I think the games are intrinsically
interesting and you know certainly a
huge part of modern human life
gamification is something very much to
worry about but T really extended it
like a good philosopher should into a
realm Way Beyond what you might guess uh
it would attach to he really emphasized
the Allure of clarity and simplicity in
World Views and models of the world and
you know I think if you would ask me
before that podcast of about how
important Clarity and simplicity are in
a good model of the world I would have
been very much in favor of them and
still am in some way but what he was
really emphasizing was there is a
downside there's a dark side to Clarity
in your view of the world trying to get
things to be too clear and too simple is
seductive because it makes you think you
have answers for everything and that
opens you up to vulnerability to being a
conspiracy theorist to generally
disdaining questioning yourself adding
new nuance and carefulness into your way
of viewing the world and that can make
you fall into a trap that can limit the
ways in which you think about and
experience the world so like many ways
going back to Aristotle uh there's a
happy medium maybe here to be struck
between looking for Simplicity and
Clarity but not thinking you have it
before you really do that's the
difficult thing to do so that's sort of
the lens with which I want to think
about these things I'm talking about you
know are people over simplifying the
world for some purportedly sensible
purpose and then having it backfire on
them so the first example is the
purchase of Twitter by Elon Musk and
again there's much to say about this and
I'm not gonna in any sense give any
comprehensive response or set of
thoughts to it it's just not something
that I've thought about systematically
in any way so it would kind of be a
little hypocritical of me to you know
pretend to have the complete theory of
that when I haven't thought about it
systematically since my whole message is
the value virtue of thinking
systematically at least the message in
this particular holiday message
um but you know it's been a mess
honestly right I'm not in favor of the
changes at Twitter since Elon bought it
there's a great increase in juvenile
trolling including by the new owner
ugly interactions lack of moderation
lack of direction for the company and so
on enough so that I personally have
downshifted my own Twitter use you know
I'm not abandoning it yet I don't think
that any of the currently existing
alternatives are comprehensive
Alternatives maybe they will go into it
I actually am not going to pretend to be
able to predict the future about Twitter
something like Twitter is really really
useful I've made friends I've learned a
lot but it's also kind of a mess in many
many ways so I'm spending less time on
social media in general and you know
this is part of just a general thought
that you know you have only finite
number of hours in the day only three
billion heartbeats in your lifetime how
are you going to spend them I did you
know just as an example put up a joke on
Twitter right is after Elon had bought
it and people were complaining that I
was going to crash and things like that
and uh I said well you know maybe it
would just be a good thing if we took
the year off and read some books and
because it's Twitter people immediately
misinter interpreted it in an
uncharitable way as we should quit our
jobs and do nothing but read books when
really I was just talking about
switching off social media and reading
books instead
um and therefore I was criticized for
being too Bourgeois and wealthy and not
understanding people's real lives and
the whole bit this is part of the
problem with the twitter-like
conversation system but the point being
that you know there is a time and place
for quick hit reactions for
instantaneous takes or whatever and
there's also a time and place for
getting deep into something and maybe
we've lost a balance there a little bit
and so rather than giving a
comprehensive response to the new regime
at Twitter I do want to just focus in on
this idea that Elon or whoever is is
helping him have just been way too
simplistic about how this should and
does work this is shown in you know they
released a whole bunch of text messages
that Elon had been sending about the
Twitter acquisition before it actually
happened one of which was from some CEO
who says step one solve free speech
I'm not making this up
so you know that just reveals so much
just that I mean maybe it was not meant
to be entirely serious but the idea that
it is not simply parodying something but
at least you know meant to be pointing
in the correct direction is just so
absurd to me and it pains me deeply
because I think that the issue of free
speech is super duper important not and
I mean that both because I think that
free speech is important but also what
restrictions we should have on free
speech and in which context we should
have them is super difficult this this
is exactly an issue that requires really
really carefully thinking about it
because it's not an absolutist yes or no
thing it is a quintessential example of
balancing different kinds of values and
different kinds of goals and that's
always going to be tricky you always
have to sit down and think about it
carefully just listen to the podcast I
did a few years ago with Teresa Beijing
about the history of it and in the other
modern version of it and you know Teresa
is someone who is a free speech scholar
and has thought about it a lot and she
will admit and did a bit of the podcast
you know she started off pretty hardcore
about being a free speech absolutist but
has seen her thinking on that sort of
become more nuanced and careful as you
think about it and what I see happening
online
is that the phrase free speech is sort
of degenerating from a crucially
important political philosophical
concept into a slogan it becomes a
tribal identifier right you know are you
in favor of free speech are you or are
you in favor of suppression of alternate
ideas because you can't handle the truth
and that that's a level of Simplicity
that the conversation is is degenerating
into same thing with words like woke or
politically correct or whatever they
become slogans by people who want to
make a point with them and use them for
political advantage and that makes it
harder no matter what you might think
about it no matter which side you're on
about any of these issues it makes it
harder to have a careful conversation
because people want to load on a bunch
of connotations for political purposes
to these existing phrases and so free
speech is becoming like that and
everyone knows when Elon Musk bought
Twitter you know he came in and saying
comedy is now allowed on Twitter free
speech is returned etc etc we're not
going to do anything except obey the law
so if something is illegal we're going
to get rid of it and if something is not
we're going to leave it on
turns out it's trickier than that it
turns out that that's a hard thing to do
even if you just did that there's
different countries with different laws
it turns out to be really difficult even
to implement that way over simplistic
version of a moderation policy what do
you and people wrote about this I'm
sorry I forget
um the names and the ability to
therefore cite them but as soon as it
happened the purchase you know people
who were very very experienced in this
field basically wrote articles saying
here's how it's going to go you're going
to say oh you can do whatever you want
on Twitter it's completely free speech
and then someone's going to say well
what about you know death threats you go
oh no okay no death threats well what
about hardcore pornography well no no
hardcore pornography and then what you
realize very very Sim very very quickly
is you are drawing a line everyone draws
a line between what is permitted and
what is not permitted I mean there is
just an example literally today as I'm
recording this where Elon famously said
that he is such a big believer in free
speech that he would not disturb the
Twitter account of the guy who tracks
his private plane
guess what he just got rid of the
Twitter account of the guy who tracks
his private plane and also all that
guy's other Twitter accounts it's hard
and I'm not saying that he should or
shouldn't do that I'm saying it's hard
and you have to think about it because
there's no magic formula you have to
list all of the different considerations
and see how you personally value them
and then guess what you have to talk to
other people to see how they value
different things because they might not
value them in the same way and if you're
doing something that involves a
community
getting input and getting the uh
opinions of the community is going to
turn out to be really really useful so I
think it's just a classic example of
coming in thinking that this field you
know nothing about is going to be pretty
easy to fix you know any possible
complications that people might have had
in mind was just because they were
prisoners of some outdated political
point of view and then finding out in
the harsh light of day that's actually
quite nuanced and tricky whether you
like it or not
I will say uh parenthetically again not
having thought of it very deeply myself
but it seems to me like some people are
pointing at the idea that if you do want
to do it correctly the real problem is
not where to draw the line between
what's allowed on Twitter and what's not
allowed on Twitter but the procedural
question about who gets to moderate I
mean really the problem is not well one
of the problems anyway is not just what
got moderated and what didn't but that
the process for moderating things was
entirely opaque and it was in the hands
of a very small number of people and
that there's a scaling problem because
any social media platform generally has
a huge number of users compared to the
number of people working at the company
right so that's why when you get a tweet
deleted or a Facebook message deleted or
whatever it can be really really hard to
figure out why and it's very very opaque
they don't tell you what the standards
are they don't tell you why you
personally have been blocked or banned
or whatever and that's very very
frustrating trading so Noah Smith on
Twitter has been emphasizing the
superiority in social media contexts of
community moderation and I think that's
a very likely to be true idea you know I
would I'd like to see more data and
empirical analysis about it but you
should have the ability for communities
to self-organize and decide what they
think is a good moderation strategy I
know that Mastodon is doing something
like that Mastodon is one of the Twitter
Alternatives it has its own problems but
uh I mean certainly the interface is
super clunky and very hard to use one of
Twitter's advantages and attractions was
always how easy it was and not everyone
catches on to the importance of that but
you know maybe something like that will
happen Jack Dorsey who was the founder
and CEO former CEO of Twitter also has
made very clear that he thinks now that
their problem was they were too opaque
and they were trying to do it top down
rather than having Community moderation
has some sort of secret Twitter
alternative project Jack Dorsey that
he's working on that is supposed to
remove social media from being owned by
anybody uh I forget what it's called but
something like that might be the future
you know it's it's just
this is and there's a whole nother
interesting thing to think about from
the perspective of complex systems
research right because
there is a thought that you can just
think really hard and anticipate what
all the problems are going to be and
then write rules this is the
bureaucratic uh trap right the
bureaucratic trap is I can think ahead
to every possible circumstance that will
happen in the future write a set of
rules that will deal with it and it
always fails you know this is why
bureaucracies are horrible because they
can't anticipate all the possible
situations that a complex system will
find itself in that's why you need some
kind of agency some kind of ability for
a smart careful considering person to
think about the actual situation you're
in maybe it's unanticipated or
unprecedented and deal with that in some
way or have a community do it not
necessarily an individual it's that
top-down thinking you can predict
everything
um belief that just gets you in trouble
with all sorts of complex systems
whether it's a car or a university or a
social media platform so I think there's
a clearly a flaw here uh in the the idea
that you just assume everything will be
easy and then what happens is you
announce that you're gonna do something
it fails you have to move back you know
again just as I'm beginning to record
this there's a story on Gizmodo about
Twitter and how you know Elon Musk has
scared away various advertisers so he's
looking for other ways to make money and
he says that Gizmodo says there's a
strategy being uh debated I guess
Twitter HQ
that says that there's a new strategy
that may mandate that you share your
location information and let Twitter
sell your data to third parties and the
company May compel your consent for
targeted advertising using your contacts
and phone number that you provided for
two-factor authentication this is almost
certainly illegal the article continues
on Gizmodo but you know this is an
example of well we're gonna try
something we don't know if it's going to
work but you know uh let's let's just
see what happens because we're kind of
desperate
now again as I said at the beginning I
don't want to be too one-sided here
because it's a balancing issue once
again it's not just a balancing issue
between different competing interests
and therefore the issue is difficult but
there are good reasons to move fast and
break things sometimes you know uh we
can be in situations again with complex
systems where you're in what is called a
rugged Fitness landscape in complex
systems research and also in
evolutionary biology a fitness landscape
is you have some space of all possible
choices space of all possible
configurations or genomes or systems or
networks or whatever it is and all of
these specific configurations that you
can imagine have a fitness how well they
do in their environment or how well they
do it the task they're trying to work at
and because the space of parameters is
so large whether it's your genome or
whether it's just all the different
possible moderation policies that we
could have on Twitter these are complex
systems and maybe you're in a situation
where given what your current choices
are there's no short simple easy change
you could make that it would improve
your life you are at a peak a local
maximum in the fitness landscape
everywhere you change by a little bit
things would get worse but somewhere
over there pass to the valley there's an
even higher peak in the fitness
landscape right there is a way to evolve
if you're in evolutionary biology to an
even better way of doing things but you
can't get there incrementally you have
to go through a worse off situation
before you can get that Advantage so
this is always a tricky thing in
evolutionary biology how do you get
there sometimes it takes sort of a
disaster right the Cambrian explosion
you get a whole bunch of extinctions
opening up new niches and then you can
explore in a more open-ended way and
that's how you find this new even higher
Fitness Peak so that's a reason to move
fast and break things there are ruts
that we have to get out of and there's a
there's a set of contexts in which that
works very well and not less
analogically and in the real world it
works very well in startups right if
you're starting something brand new
there's clearly a value in doing
something totally different right doing
something really really new is more
likely to be the next big thing but then
when we're evaluating who has done well
there's a huge selection effect there's
a thousand people trying something new
and crazy most new and crazy things fail
and we look at the one that succeeds and
go aha genius they tried something new
and crazy right there's a it's exactly
like mutations mutations in evolutionary
biology for an established organism are
usually bad there can be beneficial
mutations but they're exceedingly rare
so we don't just say oh let's just
mutate our genome from generation to
generation because we might get better
at it there's a difference between being
early in the evolutionary history of
life which is like being a startup
versus being later in the evolutionary
history of life where we figured some
things out when you're running something
established Elon Musk did not come in
and found Twitter it was already up and
running and pretty big right so there's
all this complexity all this
interconnectedness it's like any
computer programmer knows when you're
trying to improve some Legacy code when
you have some code that has been going
on for decades and you've been building
on it and modifying it you don't know
what's going to happen when you delete
some module or some subroutine or
something like that you can't see that
it has any use but somehow it's really
really important in a way that you don't
know that's again the nature of complex
systems and indeed in evolutionary
biology the rate of mutations was way
higher early in the history of life than
it is now
you know I think in some sense and I
know not everyone agrees but I think
that Elon Musk is in some sense very
sincere about his care for Humanity in
the earth you know he could have done
many things to make money but uh between
SpaceX and Tesla uh as an electric car
company I think that he really did a
huge amount to change the world in ways
that most people don't now
that's not to say that he's at all good
at hurt at helping actual people along
the way his track record at dealing with
employees and things like that is very
very bad okay but I don't think that
he's sort of an evil genius I think that
he in his mind is perfectly sincere
about saving Humanity he's just not been
very good at it in his late phase
what is going on now let's put it in in
his career okay which is a little bit
different than the other example uh
which is SPF Sam bankman freed and the
FTX crypto exchange where uh unlike with
Twitter where I'm an active user I know
nothing about the world of crypto Etc
but how can you help but be drawn in to
this story this guy this young guy Sam
bankman freed uh had a net wealth that
went from 26 billion dollars estimated
to zero in a remarkably short period of
time uh because of the collapse of his
crypto exchange FTX and it was not just
bad management it seems very very clear
that there was outright fraud going on
in a lot of ways and just like Elon Musk
turns out to be you know inveterate uh
oversharer on the internet uh SPF as he
is known uh has done a lot of interviews
since his collapse where he basically
says oh yeah you know a lot of the stuff
I did was just
kind of fooling people to get them to
give me money
and then you know he claims he's not
responsible for the actual fraud but it
kind of seems like he is it's pretty
clear that he is and the question is and
so you know a lot of people invested a
lot of people put their money in his
crypto exchange and lost it a huge
number of people and not just people off
the street there was a community he uh
one of sbf's strategies was he was
extremely active in effective altruism
which uh our former podcast guest will
mccaskill was a founder of is a founder
of and is still very active in and Will
was very close to SPF in fact introduced
SPF and Elon Musk to each other I don't
think they did anything together but uh
that he tried and so you can ask how can
uh someone who I think is extremely
smart and is absolutely a hundred
percent sincere like will mccaskill how
can he get taken in by someone who is
more or less clearly not like SBF and
you know there's probably lots of
psychological explanations there but
I think that part of it is a way that we
think about smartness right you know
there's a there's a couple of a couple
of little factoids that I will share
that shaped my thinking here one is
there's this video uh that you can see
of there's a Infamous pitch to investors
that SPF was doing he was doing a zoom
call where he was you know trying to get
people to invest and you know when
you're doing a zoom call you're you know
your eyes are glancing around you know
you're not necessarily making eye
contact maybe your camera is not where
you're uh screen is ETC okay so it's a
little bit different kind of interaction
but it turns out he was playing video
games the whole time and you know while
he was he was talking right he was
making sense and he was making his pitch
but he was he was not completely
concentrating on the task at hand he was
playing a video game in the background
and
the interesting thing is not that the
interesting thing is that the investors
when they found out thought it was
awesome they're like wow how smart is
this guy that he can make such a smooth
slick talking pitch like that while his
attention is distracted by a video game
and that just amazes me this is why I'll
never be an investor I'd be like how
what why in the world would that be
considered good why in the world would
you find out that someone was completely
their attention was completely elsewhere
while they were asking you to give them
a whole bunch of money and go wow that
person's really smart that I'm not gonna
say what my response would be but it
would not be that let's let's uh just
put it that way it's a valorization of a
kind of glib quickness and fast talking
over careful thought I see this in guest
suggestions for the podcast all the time
I get lots of great guest suggestions
for mindscape and I often take them many
of my guests have been people I didn't
know about before but people suggested
them so I looked them up but I get way
more suggestions than I can possibly
ever take and some of them are you know
you should talk to this person because
they're really really smart
and I and I say like well okay what are
they smart about what have they done
what you know what is the topic that
they're that they know more about than
anyone else and the answer is like
everything they just good at everything
they have a take on absolutely
everything in the world
um that is a complete turn off to me
that gives me a very bad feeling I'm
instantly uh repelled by that idea you
know it's it's there's value and it's
good to be quick and to have opinions
about things breadth is good but so is
depth you need a little bit of both
again you know there's there's if you're
going to be a pundit if you're going to
be just a commentator then that kind of
breadth and um
ability to bounce back and forth from
topic to topic is very valuable and SAS
let's put it in the most positive light
that we can right and there's an
absolutely a place for that a Critic an
essayist there's absolutely a place but
mostly not exclusively but mostly I'm
looking for the depth when I'm here on
the podcast I'm looking for people who
have really thought through the nuances
of something uh as a person I would want
both as a podcast guest I'm looking more
for the depth the other clue and again
I'm going to keep saying this over and
over again I have not read very
carefully about this I'm just giving my
off the cuff opinions
um but there's a quote by SBF where he
told a journalist that he thinks every
book is a mistake he would never read a
book
no one should ever write books every
book should just be a blog post it's a
waste of time
and again I'm thinking wow like how in
the world could uh so many smart people
think that that was the sign of a true
genius person who's going to make a lot
of money and make the world a better
place there's warning signs here you're
ignoring the red flags
to me like I I think that even if you
want some new Hot Shot brand new idea
get it from someone who shows some
interest in being a little more careful
and deep than that
and with that uh let's switch gears a
little bit for me to talk about
foundations of physics which sounds like
a completely different topic and and is
a completely different topic but there's
a through line here once again
um and by the way I should tell you what
I mean by foundations of physics because
it's a slightly different thing
philosophy of physics is of course a
well-established field as his
foundations of physics but the more
common phrase you will hear is
philosophy of physics or philosophy of
science and Foundations is sort of some
maybe a subset of philosophy of physics
but also you can do foundations of
physics without being a philosopher at
all just sort of a certain kind of
careful deep way of doing physics
philosophy of physics might include a
lot of you know Theory choice and
methodology and epistemology or even
history of physics whereas foundations
of physics is really the same goal as
physics philosophy physics is sometimes
trying to describe and understand the
process by which physics gets done
foundations of physics is trying to
understand the universe is trying to
understand nature is trying to
understand reality just like physics is
but it's doing it in a way right it's a
style within the our attempts to
understand nature sure better and I was
thinking about this because I gave an
introductory talk here at Johns Hopkins
at the physics department a little talk
on you know foundations of physics boot
camp what ways what is foundations of
physics and in what ways might it be
helpful to actual working physicists so
I had a chance to think about what the
answer to that question is and there's
lots of answers and it's actually a case
where it's probably better to just so go
through the examples and decide for
yourself what their commonality is but
one theme I kept returning to was
patience
in other words the idea of being willing
to say well why is that true okay why is
that true why exactly is is this thing
true physicists as much as I love them
in M1 of them they are very happy to get
the right answer for the wrong reasons
they are very very focused on getting
the right answer saying the thing is the
what the thing is that nature does that
will be predicted by their models that
will be seen by their experiments that's
not a bad thing you know getting the
right answer is a very very good thing
but sometimes you get the right answer
and you don't have real Clarity on why
you've gotten it but you have a set of
things you can say that are kind of good
enough right quantum mechanics is the
obvious example here where almost 100
years after the Solvay conference we
still don't have a consensus on what's
going on in quantum mechanics but we
have no trouble using it right we can
make the predictions for the the lhce or
for superconductors or whatever without
knowing the ontology of quantum
mechanics and as you know if you listen
to me I'm talking about these things the
vast vast majority of physicists are
perfectly happy with that you know it's
one thing to say that we have a
challenge there's something we don't
understand there's always things we
don't understand the weird thing about
the foundations of quantum mechanics is
how happy we are with not understanding
you know with we're professional
physicists and yet we're perfectly
content to leave some of these really
really deep questions about physics
by the wayside and I think that's kind
of wrong and it's not only quantum
mechanics in Quantum field Theory there
are deep foundational questions uh
there's something called hogs theorem
h-a-a-g Rudolph Hogg which was developed
by other people also but
and I'm not going to go into it because
it's very very nuanced and even the
philosophers and Foundation people
foundations of physics people argue
about what it says and what it means but
basically the seeming implication of
Hog's theorem is that there's a way that
in Quantum field Theory we go about
actually doing calculations which is we
often turn off the interactions of our
electrons and photons for example so we
can just understand what the world would
be like if there were no interactions or
just electrons or photons flying freely
not interacting with each other
and then we turn on the interactions let
them interact and then turn them back
off again and we sort of try to match
the behavior of the interacting Theory
to the non-interacting theory to make a
prediction and roughly speaking Hog's
theorem says that you can't do this that
you can't do this in a way that
preserves a lot of the structure you
want to preserve like the behavior of
different fields and their commutation
relations and so forth so
this naively says you know again naively
that everything we do to make
predictions at Large Hadron colliders
complete nonsense but guess what it
works really really well so I know that
it works and it does work for a reason
but we're not very sure what that reason
is and to me I would like to be more
sure what that reason is
um and maybe the reason is simple but
it's not something I don't think we
currently understand and there's other
examples as well the arrow of time the
fact that you need a past hypothesis of
early low entropy is something that is
just not understood by most physicists
who are teaching statistical mechanics
the foundations of statistical mechanics
is a very important and open area in my
own field whether it's cosmology or
particle physics we talk a lot about
fine-tuning and naturalness you know
whether certain parameters are natural
whether fine-tuned whether we should be
surprised whether you need a Multiverse
whether you know there's some dynamical
mechanisms guess what
we have not as a physics Community
thought very carefully about what that
means uh some people have tried they've
not done a great job honestly but so
again we're using these ideas without
knowing exactly what they're on about
because we want to hurry up and get the
answer we don't have the patience to
think really slowly about what we're
doing and there's a very strong
motivation for that getting the right
result getting the right model
predicting the outcome of the experiment
that's ultimately what we want to do and
again there's a there's an analogy with
the startups right if you try a million
different startups and most of them fail
there is a very strong weeding mechanism
right you're you're going to try to make
money you're trying to make a product
that becomes popular in the marketplace
so there is a Criterion for success and
failure likewise in physics if you have
some ideas there's a very strong
Criterion for success and failure are
you predicting the right experimental
outcomes when you're in a situation
where you have huge guidance from
experimental or empirical data wrong
ideas get shot down quickly and so go
ahead you know you can get a lot of
right ideas just because nature guides
you to them kicking and screaming
but sometimes there are important
questions for which the experimental
guidance is kind of meager right when
we're talking about why is the
cosmological constant a small number why
is the mass of the Higgs boson so much
lower than the Planck scale
these are potentially fraught questions
with sort of physical implications
because maybe the answer is something to
do with supersymmetry or some new
physics or something like that but
there's no immediate experimental
guidance to how to think about it so
what happens is the old ways of thinking
that were perfectly good when the
experiment would just tell you when you
were wrong aren't as much help in these
deeper more foundational questions and
so you need to think a little bit more
carefully you need to ask why you
thought that a certain number was
natural in the first place and so on and
I think there's a lot of ways that this
foundational thinking can help with good
old physics you know I think this is
clearly true in quantum mechanics I'm
increasingly thinking it's true in
cosmology that's one of the big things I
want to write papers about in the next
couple years I think there's sort of a
lot of ways we could improve our
understanding of naturalist and
fine-tuning in cosmology by thinking
foundationally by thinking more
carefully more slowly even than we do
so to close I'll try to give you an
example an extended story uh that that
maybe speaks to the helpfulness the
usefulness of thinking carefully and
slowly about theoretical physics even if
you don't really care about the
philosophical side of things you just
care about the physics side of things so
in the early 1950s David Bohm was a
young assistant professor at Princeton
and he ultimately got in trouble he was
he had communist sympathies he had hung
out with some uh Communists back in the
day that prevented him from working at
Los Alamos during the Manhattan Project
and in the early 50s it was the height
of the Red Scare the McCarthy era the
house on American Activities Committee
and he ran into trouble with them and
eventually the president of Princeton
locked him out of his office and fired
him and he couldn't even get jobs
anywhere in the United States he had to
move to Brazil That's not the story that
I'm thinking of I'm thinking of a
different story about David Baume in the
early 1950s which is that he wrote a
textbook on quantum mechanics and it was
a very straightforward you know
conventional wisdom textbook he was not
trying to rock the boat or anything like
that but it was still you know I
wouldn't say the early days of quantum
mechanics but things were still settling
and they were still in the Afterglow of
the early days uh where where all the
possibilities were being debated and we
hadn't quite settled in on the final
answers so boam talks about the
possibility of hidden variables in his
book so in other words the idea that it
not only is there a quantum mechanical
wave function but there are other
physical quantities that go into
determining your quantum theory
and he didn't talk about it in any great
depth he merely quoted a theorem by John
Von Neumann that proved apparently
supposedly that hidden variables were
impossible that they you could never
reproduce the success of quantum
mechanics with hidden variables the
problem is that Von Neumann's proof and
vanoine was a genius mathematical
physicist but his proof was written in
his book the foundations of quantum
mechanics and or was it that was it the
mathematical principles of quantum
mechanics I'm not going to remember the
title of Von Neumann's book but the book
had not yet been translated into English
it was only in German and like many
other Americans boom was not a German
speaker but at Princeton there was
someone who cared very very deeply about
the foundations of quantum mechanics and
did speak German namely Albert Einstein
so Einstein uh saw bohm's book and leave
leaved through it and summoned him to
his office right so when you get a
summon to go to Albert Einstein's office
you go and Einstein says you know look
you say that this thing is proven here
but he opened this Von Neumann's book in
German he says like it he's making all
these assumptions that might not be true
this doesn't prove anything at all about
the real world
and Einstein was right as Einstein very
often was and it made a big impression
on bone so boam went back and started
thinking about it and said well okay if
that proof doesn't quite prove the
sweeping conclusion that it is
apparently trying to lead to
can you make a theory of hidden
variables and so he did he made a theory
called bromine mechanics and it's
actually very close to a previous Theory
by Louis de brois so sometimes we call
it de broy bone Theory and he wrote
about it and you know the secret is to
be non-local the hidden variables in
Bones Theory have explicitly non-local
interactions what one particle at one
point in the universe is doing is
affected by other particles elsewhere
and no one cared no one was really
interested I mean uh boam's thesis
advisor was J Robert Oppenheimer who
says okay now we can just ignore him
because he's gone you know he's gone a
little crazy modifying quantum mechanics
there was one person who was not uh
unimpressed who was very very stricken
by bones result who was called John Bell
John Bell at the time was physicist at
CERN working again on very normal
Quantum field Theory particle physics
kind of problems but he had this
interest in the foundations of quantum
mechanics and he read Bells he read
bombs
um papers
and was really struck by how like
apparently bone was doing something that
was supposed to be important and he
noticed that there was non-locality in
there and so Bell says I wonder if this
non-locality that is part of Belle's uh
part of Baum's theory is necessary could
we get rid of it right and he ends up
proving Belle's theorems and deriving
the Bell inequalities which basically
says that you need some kind of
non-locality in quantum mechanics again
under certain technical assumptions you
can get rid of but it's a very sweeping
kind of thing and he he really gives
away of delineating uh which kinds of
correlations you will get in a quantum
mechanical like Theory and then some
kind of local more classical kind of
theory uh and again you know he was
hiding from his friends Bell did not
want his colleagues that started to know
about it he was working on weekends he
finished the paper during a sabbatical
the whole thing
uh and it didn't make when he publishes
papers didn't make a big splash but so
as we now know
um it did eventually make a big splash
the Bell inequalities became of great
interest to people working on Quantum
information and entanglement and the
most recent Nobel Prize was given to
clawser ospe and zeilinger for their
experimental tests of the Bell
inequalities and the punchline to this
whole story is
the Nobel committee when giving out the
press release announcing the Nobel Prize
completely got it wrong they wrote in
their press release that John Bell had
proven that hidden variable theories
were impossible
which is exactly the opposite of the
truth what he proved was that non-local
was the only way to be a hidden variable
Theory local hidden variable theories
are impossible again modulo-sum uh
possible more assumptions you have to
make but Bell was a huge booster of
hidden variable theories Bell was always
telling people that we should teach
bomine mechanics in quantum mechanical
textbooks he didn't quite absolutely
have a belief in it but his certainly
his favorite theory of quantum mechanics
was bombian mechanics so to present
Bell's theorem as a proof that hidden
variable theories can't work is exactly
backwards
so you know if even the Nobel committee
can make mistakes like this
um I think that maybe there is some
value to thinking more carefully about
these issues I think that you know
physicists absolutely do think carefully
about their narrow technical problems
that's one of the ways that physicists
have been amazingly effective at making
such enormous strides in understanding
the universe by just digging super
deeply into a particular kind of thing
and the really good ones no more than
one kind of thing and they can bring
them together and make connections and
that's great but you don't just say ah
okay it's working let's just move on
with it right I don't know how to
actually make people think more deeply
about things you know you you joke about
things I think maybe like have a new
rule where you're only allowed to
publish papers in even number years and
in odd number of years you have to read
a book or read many books or read other
people's papers I don't know what the
ways to change the incentive structures
are but I do think that whether it's
being a working physicist or a tech
Mogul trying to change the world
um we should place a little bit more
value than we do on going deeply being
patient thinking carefully thinking very
very slowly about the very difficult
questions that we're trying to address
and with that uh very
paternalistic kind of message not a
specially inspired message but I hope
one that you are prepared already to
take to heart happy holidays everybody
as you know I take next week off things
to do and
um I'll see you on the flip side early
January with a whole new year of the
mindscape podcast thanks for your
support this year take care
[Music]
la la la
[Music]